when you're trying to diagnose a
situation if you're asking an employee
and i'll give you like some of the
scripting around this at the end it's
like hey is it this like i've noticed
you're not doing this thing is it this
this or this that's causing it and then
you're not attacking the person you're
attacking the process and it makes it
much easier to talk about all right
if you deal with human beings you are
going to inevitably try to influence
them at some point to do what you would
like them to do and this happens within
the context of when you go to a
restaurant you ask waiter do you hope
that they put the thing in for you right
you want the food to come out the way
you want to come out we have desires and
demands that we make of the universe and
we want them to come back to us based on
our preferences now that being said when
we run a company right we deal with
employees and other people a lot in
order to organize them in a single
direction to get them to the outcome
that we desire all right and so i have
talked about this in the past but i will
give you alex's simplest framework which
is a triangle framework
[Music]
uh
uh it matches acquisition.com and if you
don't know why my name is alex from
rosie on acquisition.com is probably
companies that does over 100 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you i
make these videos because i want you to
make tons of money and then hopefully
partner with us in the future to get
from 3 million to 10 million to 20
million 30 million and beyond all right
awesome so let's rock and roll so one of
the easiest frameworks and i've actually
been somebody who's struggled at the
managerial side more than kind of like
the strategy or the marketing things
like that like i i've struggled more on
the managerial side so for me frameworks
here in some ways actually provide me
for more value than other frameworks
because some of these other frameworks
came more naturally to me this one did
not and this one is something that i
have stolen ruthlessly from layla
because she's the one who really does
more the managing than i do um but i'm
sharing this for the entrepreneurs of
the world because i hope that you do not
struggle as i did all right so if you
want somebody to do something and they
do not do it what do you do all right so
there are three reasons that someone
will not do something and part of this
two of these i snagged from uh andy
grove who was the founder and storied
ceo of intel uh he wrote high output
management which is an excellent
excellent book it's very it's a little
uh it's a little hot a little advanced
but it's really good so recommend that
being said he said there's only two
reasons that an employee does not do
what you want them to do which is either
they do not know how or they are not
motivated right and so he said therefore
the job of the boss is to motivate and
to train he said if you're not training
you're not motivating you're not being a
good boss and i thought that was
wonderful that being said i came up on a
circumstance in my life where both of
those situations were not actually uh
the case there was a third scenario
which came up which is why i now have a
triangle for why people uh don't do
stuff all right number one is they don't
know that you want them to do it and so
i'll tell you a quick story so i uh i
had a sales manager that i really wanted
uh to succeed right and so uh we hired
them and they were new and i was super
excited and uh you know a few weeks in i
was like hey dude had a conversation
with some of the sales guys and uh you
haven't done any call reviews wtf bro
and uh the guy was like i was unaware
that you wanted me to do call reviews i
was like well i just i mean i just
figured that's that's what you would do
as a sales rep now mind you that is
probably what they should be doing sales
director but guess what i didn't do i
didn't tell him i didn't tell him i want
him to do that and so two things here
with uh with communicating expectations
number one is you have to communicate
them number two is you have to repeat
the communication number three you have
to make sure it's documented all right
which means it's in writing in ideally
multiple places and if you can make sure
that it's part of daily or weekly
checklists or things that they report on
the things that you ask them to give you
are going to be the things that you
subconsciously communicate are important
to you all right so if you say hey i
need you to report on these three
metrics guess what they're going to
think is important to you the three
metrics if you want something to be done
make sure they are reporting it to you
on a weekly or daily basis the faster
the communication cadence that you have
around the item or task or activity or
metric the more important they will deem
it so if you meet twice a day about a
specific metric they will think it's
very important right if you meet once a
quarter and you and it's one line item
on a slide chart they will probably
think it's less than board and if you
don't report on it at all and never talk
about it all they will definitely not
think it's important and very very very
high likelihood of not doing it all
right so peak of the triangle here is
communicate the expectation it sounds
silly but when you think about this and
this is why i'm sharing this framework
is that when i have somebody who's not
doing what i would like them to do or
not adhering to the preferences that i
have i think which one of these three is
it and so it's very helpful it's also
really helpful when you're trying to
diagnose a situation if you're asking an
employee and i'll give you like some of
the scripting around this at the end
it's like hey is it this like i've
noticed you're not doing this thing is
it this this or this that's causing it
and then you're not attacking the person
you're attacking the process and it
makes it much easier to talk about all
right so that's number one number two is
training which is do you not know how to
do this thing do you not know how to do
a call review well let me tell you what
a call review looks like let's do two of
them together and we'll record the thing
so that in the future you can go back to
it right this is what we're looking for
this is the transitions this is how we
take the notes and this is how i want
you to communicate it to the sales team
aha right and so not only did we
communicate what we wanted we said hey
this is how you do it and this is how i
would like it to be done right and then
finally this is how i want you to report
on it to me so that i know it was done
right very very simple but you know what
people don't do it and being advanced is
simply never not doing the basics and i
do have a double negative there because
that makes it makes you think a little
harder but what it means is that bing
advance is always doing the basics like
that is what being advanced is is doing
the basics even while you have
tremendous volume right if you think
about this for a second when people
start small businesses they tend to grow
because they have lots of personal
interaction they provide lots of service
they service with a smile and what
happens they hire some teammates the the
service goes down there's less smiles
less skill and so what they did was they
stopped doing the basics at scale that's
all it is and that's why businesses
plateau and so it's thinking about what
are the things that made you successful
in beginning and then how can i
duplicate those at scale it's always
doing the basics that's what it is all
right so number one communicating the
expectations doing so ideally frequently
and making sure it's measured and in
writing and if we do that we have hit
the peak of the pyramid number two is
that we have the training side is that
we showed them how to do it and how we
want them to do it and how they how we
want them to report on those things all
right that's number two number three
drum roll please is
incentive is motivation is do they want
to do the thing because think about it
if i said hey dude i need you to do x y
and z right and you know how to do x y
and z and you're not doing it the reason
might be that they are unmotivated now
i'll give you the caveat here is that if
someone says i've been too busy right
now you can look at that as a because
that's usually what will happen like
let's go real world for a second right
theory sounds great but let's what's
real world they'll say i was busy
because they're not no one's gonna be
like i was not motivated right so part
of that could be motivation right
because if i said hey if i give you ten
thousand dollars to get this done by
tomorrow will you do it they probably
would so i think with enough motivation
they can do it but that being said they
might also not have the training know
how to manage their schedule in a way uh
to prioritize these activities so you
might have to train them on other
components to make sure that it's easier
for them right now that being said when
you introduce that these three
frameworks i just love it from a
conversational perspective and how to
assess and problems so if you have a
teammate so this is for you right now
real world if you have a teammate or a
director or manager or an individual
contributor who's in the company and
they are not doing things to the extent
that you want them to to the quality you
want them to at the speed that you want
them to or they're just not doing it at
all think about using this three that's
this three-prong framework which is like
hey johnny you're underperforming right
now and it's really unlike you right and
the reason we say that is because it
also embeds a compliment which is like
it's not like you to suck right and so
all automatically we're actually
protecting the ego of the person while
still attacking the behavior all right
it's really nuanced i learned that one
from layla just being real but it works
really really well she said hey it's not
like you to be late for stuff so what's
going on right it's not like you did not
get your ender week reports in like
what's going on right and this is where
when you say that what's going on it's
you look through the three lenses like
what's going on is it you didn't know
that i wanted you to do it did i not
communicate it well is it that you don't
know how to do it either in general or
given your workload or is it that you're
not motivated to do it right are there
other priorities that are more
motivating for you to do right and so
when you ask those questions it gives
them very clear boxes to direct their
their replies and then you can isolate
the issue and then you can solve it and
the thing is is if you have the three
boxes and you can isolate the issue and
then you take the actions to solve it
and if the activity still doesn't happen
then you say hey we talked about these
three boxes we solved the problem like i
can't say we haven't communicated so is
it just a motivation issue right and so
at that point then you can get into a
little bit more real conversations like
you know what i actually hate this job
and you're like you know like we hate
having you i'm kidding you don't you
wouldn't say that
you could say you'd say oh my gosh that
sucks let's see and if you like the
person they're a cultural fit and they
have other skills you may be like well
maybe there's another role in the
company that would fit you i would say
nine times out of ten that's what you
want to do it's usually not the right
call because usually if you were to hire
somebody for this other position that
you might have opened the company you
should probably just hire the person
that you would normally hire there
because if you look at that person and
this person and a track record of
failure does not make it a high
likelihood candidate all right so big
picture for everyone use the triangle of
figuring out why people do not do the
things that you want them to do which is
one that i communicate the expectation
to you am i doing it with adequate
importance to tell you how important
this is to me which is frequency and
detail of communication and making sure
that it's recorded down right the
training oops that's the side of the
triangle the training is that i actually
show them how to do it and then how to
manage the other things in general that
they are doing so they can get all this
stuff done yes check that box and then
finally are they motivated or
incentivized in order to get this done
and so i talked about their internal
motivation but there's also external
motivation which is like do i need to do
i need to realign their bonus structure
do i need to rely on how they're getting
compensated because if for example i
asked them to do this thing and they're
getting compensated for four other
things and they don't get compensated
for this extra thing well then guess
what they're probably not going to be
motivated to do the thing so we have to
make sure that they are properly
motivated you know internally as a human
being in terms of their aligned with the
company they see why this thing actually
makes a difference all right this is a
this is my last little little tidbit on
this is that people a lot of times just
want to know why just why why am i doing
this and if you if someone understands
why they're because otherwise activity
without purpose is what they do at
prison camps right it's pointless labor
right and so that's the thing it's like
you have to give it a point you have to
give it a purpose right which is like
when you update the crm with the notes
from your calls it helps finance it
helps judy in finance actually have good
conversations with these people which
helps us collect more money and helps us
get more people staying on track right
it helps uh cindy in customer success on
the onboarding give them a much more
personalized experience so we want to
sell something great right don't you
want to sell something great well if you
don't put notes in you're actually
selling something that's worse because
we're going to provide a worse
experience for them right and so they're
going to get on the onboarding call and
we're going to be able to have no
personality we're not going to know what
their issues are we're not going to know
what their pains are we're not going to
know what they're struggling with and
then we can't even help them more so
you're going to try and sell them this
amazing solution and then we're not
you're not giving us the the ammo to
actually do the things that you have
just promised them oh right and the
other reason we do this is because for
us to not waste your time so now i just
did two benefits to the global benefit
which let's be real a lot of people
might care about if they're good people
but a lot of people do not so but for
you specifically when you leave the
notes it helps us screen out candidates
on the front end so that we can use that
data to make your call likelihood of
close higher so that a higher percentage
of your time is spent closing people and
talking to people who have the money who
have the problems that we actually fix
rather than wasting time with tire
kickers and people who are probably not
going to buy does that make sense right
so when you do this we help you sell
more and make more money fair enough
great and so you can appeal to the the
larger picture of like why do we need
this as an organization but then also if
you can ideally tie it back to a
personal benefit uh to why it benefits
them a lot of people just don't know and
so just explaining that process you hit
all three of the triangle boxes and you
are far more likely to get somebody who
does the things that you're asking to do
so that your company can grow the way
that you want it to so you can make all
the money in the world and then wonder
why you did it to begin with all right
motivation keeping awesome lots of love
and i'll catch you guys next video bye
mostly nation you guys are the best and
if you could do me the biggest favor for
the entire world click the like button
comment below so i can answer more of
your questions in the videos and make
sure that i'm not just making stuff out
of my head but answering the questions
you guys actually want like comment i'll
see you in the next